I'm a dietitian so I obviously love
salad let me show you what I get at
Sweet greens
I usually like to build my own Bowl my
way but they get the most amazing
sounding seasonal special with like lots
of Brussels sprouts and chicken sweet
potato apples nuts all the good stuff so
I went for it literally everything at
Sweet greens is super delicious and the
portions are pretty generous so we've
got lots of fiberage veg between the
Brussels sprouts and all the lettuce in
there we got fiber rich carbs in our
apple plus our sweet potato protein in
our chicken healthy fats in the dressing
and the nuts and a little extra carbs on
the side
yoga